hello
i'm alexander rose the executive
director here at long now
today i'm going to be joined by sean
carroll from caltech and santa fe
institute
who's a theoretical physicist who's been
really studying
the nature of time itself and the human
experience of time and really how we fit
in it and here at long now we've been
doing talks
that kind of relate to time in many ways
but this is the first time that we're
doing it on time
itself i'm very excited to have sean
here welcome
sean carroll thanks very much sander
it's a great pleasure to be
talking about time the nature of time
what it means for all of us
at the long now foundation obviously
folks along now have been thinking very
carefully about time
about the human aspects of time about
how to measure it how to
think about it and that's my jam that's
what i'm very
very interested in doing you know time
is just so
important to who we are as human beings
right we feel like
time is passing around us or we're
flowing through time
the metaphors they go back and forth i'm
not sure whether we're moving
through time or time is moving around us
but either way
time is just crucial to what it means to
be a person we plan for the future we
remember the past
some of us are so fascinated by the
nature of time that we become
professional physicists and we learn
about what time means from the
physicist's point of view
and we learn a lot like physicists
understand a great deal
about the nature of time but there's
something interesting
maybe a little scary that happens when
you learn about time from the
perspective of physicists you learn
equations they tell you how physical
systems evolve
but this idea that time passes
or the time flows or that somehow we
move through
time that central most obvious idea
about time in our everyday lives
disappears it's nowhere to be found in
the fundamental laws of physics but it's
clearly there
in our everyday lives and we think that
we're made of things that follow the
fundamental laws of physics so
what is going on that's what i want to
talk about with you
today how to reconcile how physicists
think about time with how we experience
it in our everyday lives
and what that reconciliation teaches us
for what time means and what it means to
be a person
so let me start by explaining what i
mean when i say that this
passage of time notion disappears when
you learn about time from the physicist
point of view
what does a physicist do what's a
typical physicist kind of problem
to contemplate okay well think about the
planets
in the solar system moving around the
sun this is the kind of thing that
physicists are really good at
paradigmatic kepler galileo newton those
people
you're given the state of some physical
system by which
in this case we mean the positions of
all the planets where they're located in
space
and how they're moving right the
velocity at just one moment of time you
don't need to be given the history of
the planets
at one moment of time you're given where
they are
and how they're moving right now and
then you have
a recipe you have the laws of physics
you have newton's laws of motion
and newton's law of gravitation and from
those
you can predict the future from the
present state of the system you can tell
where it's going to be next you can
predict eclipses in the future
you can say where the planets are going
to be you can make an almanac okay
but there's something extra that is very
very important you can
also predict the past or retrodict if
you prefer
given the current state of the system
the laws of physics tell you
exactly what was going on in the entire
past history of the system
and real astronomers actually do this
they extrapolate the current state of
the solar system
millions or billions of years into the
past and the future
so buried underneath that little
discussion
is an idea that we call conservation of
information
all of the information you need about
the system right now its positions its
velocities and so forth
suffices to predict the entire future
and past
of the system if i told you exactly the
state of the system
a million years ago you could predict
what it would be doing
right now this is the disappearance of
this idea that time is flowing
time to a physicist ever since isaac
newton
it becomes kind of a label there's this
moment there's the past moment there's
the future moment
there's nothing special about what we
call now or the present moment
the laws of physics describe every
moment of time
as being on an equal footing and the
information contained in every moment of
time
persists into the past and the future
that's very different from what we're
used to in our everyday lives just as
one simple example
imagine you come across there's a glass
of water on the table it's a
slightly cool glass of water okay and
you ask yourself well
what was the state of that glass of
water a few minutes ago
maybe it was just a cool glass of water
just sitting there but maybe
it was a glass of room temperature water
with some ice cubes in it and maybe
those ice cubes
melted and cooled off the water the
point is
just given the macroscopic observable
information about the world
you can't say where it came from
unlike the perfect information we have
for the solar system in the real world
where we see the glass of water and we
can see a little bit about it right it's
temperature whether there's ice in it or
not
but we're not looking at every atom or
molecule of water
then suddenly information is no longer
conserved
there's information that used to be
there in the system did it have an ice
cube in it or not
and that's disappeared over time we have
an
irreversible process so what we're
seeing in the macroscopic world
is what scientists and philosophers call
the arrow of time
the difference between the past and the
future in particular
the asymmetry that we have when we think
about
now versus the past versus the future
and that asymmetry that arrow of time is
not there in the fundamental laws of
physics we have to dig in
a little bit to understand where it
comes from so let me just explain
how that asymmetry between past and
future shows up
in our everyday lives one aspect is that
there is an asymmetry of
knowledge okay in a very real sense
you can predict the future but you're
never really sure what's going to happen
right you know sometimes our predictions
come out wrong whereas when it comes to
the past we can have
records we can have memories there are
things that exist
in the universe right now which we're
very very confident
tell us something specific about an
event that happened in the past whether
it's a photograph
or a book or a fossil a bone underneath
the earth
these are artifacts right now that
represent something definite about the
past we don't have
photographs or artifacts that tell us
about the future in the same way
but there's another asymmetry not just
knowledge between past and future
there's an asymmetry of
influence between the past and future we
have in our minds the idea the past is
settled
right it happened there's nothing you
can do about it whereas
toward the future we can make choices
we can do things now that affect the
future
if you lift your left hand versus
lifting your right hand
that might have an impact on the future
but nobody thinks
that by doing something right now you
can influence
the past where did these asymmetries
come from
why is it that we can know more about
the past but we can influence the future
in some way
again it's nowhere in newton's laws of
motion
okay nor in any update of newton's laws
of motion general relativity
electromagnetism
schrodinger's equation in quantum
mechanics all of these attempts
at finding a fundamental laws of physics
have the feature
that they treat the past present and
future equally
now i'm not going to hold you in
suspense too much i actually know the
answer to this question
why is the past present and future so
different to us
the answer is something called entropy
and the second law of thermodynamics i'm
sure you've heard about this
before entropy is basically roughly not
exactly but close enough
the disorderliness of a system the
randomness the disorganization
and there is a law of nature that is
true in our macroscopic everyday world
that says that entropy increases over
time so a typical example
might be an egg you can have an unbroken
egg it's easy enough
to break the egg to scramble the egg and
in that process
from unbroken to broken to scrambled the
entropy of the egg increases you're
mixing things up you're making them more
random and that would just happen very
easily and naturally in the world
whereas
if you saw a movie of scrambled eggs
reforming into an unbroken egg
you would know right away someone was
playing the movie
backwards in time there's a
directionality to the evolution of these
systems
so the first law of thermodynamics just
says energy is constant that's good
the second law says that entropy
increases over time in a closed
isolated system or in the universe as a
whole you can clean up your room don't
get me wrong
you can lower the entropy in a localized
system by influencing it from the
outside world
but overall in the universe as a whole
entropy
increases over time so unlike newton's
laws or other attempts at fundamental
laws of physics
the second law of thermodynamics does
tell the difference between the past
present and future it says that entropy
will be higher in the future it was
lower in the past good that's nice
that's an explanation of something but
we want to do better why is it the case
why does entropy go up over time so this
was
roughly speaking solved in the 1870s by
ludwig boltzmann an austrian physicist
and some of his friends
what they did was they said entropy is
not just a rough idea it's a highly
precise
quantitative concept that we can attach
equations to that's what physicists like
to do with their lives
attach equations to things you thought
you understood so
entropy in boltzmann formulation is just
look when you look at a system
a macroscopic thing a glass of water
with an ice cube in it or cream and
coffee or an egg
you don't see every little bit of that
system you don't see the molecules you
don't see the atoms of which it is made
so let's take cream and coffee as a
classic example okay
if the cream and coffee are separate
from each other
there's a number of ways you could
imagine changing the positions
of the individual molecules in the cream
or molecules in the coffee
so that macroscopically you wouldn't be
able to tell the difference
but if you started mixing them together
if you started taking the cream and
mixing into the coffee you would be able
to tell the difference so there's a
small number of rearrangements you could
imagine
whereas if it's all mixed up right if
all the cream and all the coffee are
mixed together
then there are a large number of ways
you can rearrange the atoms and
molecules
to make it look exactly the same so
boltzmann says
that's what entropy is entropy is a way
of counting
how many ways there are to rearrange the
fundamental constituents of a system
so that it macroscopically looks the
same
to us from that point of view it's not
at all surprising that entropy
goes up as a function of time it's
simply because there are
more ways to be high entropy than to be
low entropy
if you have a medium entropy system and
just let it go
let it do its thing let it evolve into
the universe
it will naturally increase in entropy
since there are so many more
configurations that look that way
that part is easy the hard part is
if you have a medium entropy system why
was it lower entropy in the past
if it started lower entropy you can
explain why but
you seem to need a new principle to
explain that and indeed
that is exactly true think of the arrow
of time this way
there's no arrow of space right if you
were an astronaut floating out there in
space there'd be no difference between
up down left right forward backward
but you know if you're here on earth
there's an arrow of space you can tell
the difference between up and down
nobody thinks that arrow of space is
deeply ingrained in the fundamental
nature of reality
it's just because you're in the vicinity
of an influential object
the earth the same story is true for the
arrow of time the arrow of time
according to modern physics
is not built into the fundamental nature
of reality
we experience it because we live in the
aftermath of an influential event
the big bang 14 billion years ago
for reasons that cosmologists do not
understand
the big bang was very low entropy
the early universe was very orderly
compared to what it could have been now
why is that true good question very
active research question
at the frontiers of modern cosmology but
for our purposes today
we don't know why but it's true the big
bang had a low entropy and once you say
that
it's clear that entropy is going to go
up it's been going up for the last 14
billion years it's going to continue to
go up
billions and billions of years into the
future
so good we think we know what entropy is
the number of ways you can rearrange a
system
we think it makes sense that entropy
increases over time
what we're left to do is understand what
this has to do
with our experience of time in the
everyday world
how does that help explain this
asymmetry we have about the past versus
the future
this feeling that we have that we're
flowing through time
well let's just take one example here's
my favorite example of an
asymmetry this is an asymmetry of
prediction
versus records you're walking down the
street you look down the sidewalk you
see a broken egg can we ask ourselves
because we're in a philosophical mood
what is the future of that egg likely to
hold
you don't know right there's many
different possible things that could
happen to the egg it could just sit
there
it could be cleaned up by somebody there
could be a rainstorm washing it away
there's many possible futures open but
if you ask yourself
what does the past of that egg probably
involve
with very high confidence you will
believe that there used to be an
unbroken egg
and it got dropped and it broke so right
away
just seeing this thing in the world
right now this artifact
broken egg on the sidewalk you infer a
difference
between the past history of that egg and
the future history of that egg
why well it's not because of the
fundamental laws of physics
given the configuration today egg on the
ground
messy etc there are many many
arrangements
of the individual molecules that could
account for that
and accordingly there are many many
possible futures as we said many things
could happen
to the egg if all you knew were the
fundamental laws of physics
there is a precisely equal number of
past things that the egg could have gone
through
the conservation of information
convinces us that the number of
past possible histories of that egg is
exactly equal
to the number of future possible
histories of that egg
but there is one big difference that we
know the universe started with a big
bang
and that big bang had a very low entropy
this is what
philosophers call the past hypothesis of
low entropy
in the universe so we know two things we
know the current state of the egg
and we know the initial condition that
we started with very low entropy
we that's where the imbalance comes from
that's where we know
a little bit something more about the
past than about the future and we can
use that information
to say given the existence of a broken
egg on the sidewalk today
and the existence of a very very low
entropy big bang
we can infer that there used to be an
unbroken egg
as you go through your life as you are
remembering things and predicting things
about the future you are
constantly relying on the fact that the
entropy of the universe was very low
near the big bang
you might not have known that you are
relying on that fact but it's crucially
important
to how we live our lives that's the good
news we can say something
about where this asymmetry comes from
this asymmetry of
both knowledge and influence toward the
past and the future
but it raises kind of another worry that
we didn't have before
which is the following you know if all
that happens over the history of the
universe
is that disorder increases how did i get
here
i think of myself as relatively orderly
right the organs of my body the neurons
in my brain they're organized in kind of
a precise way
how could you tell me that something as
exquisitely organized as a living being
just came to exist out of increasing
entropy over time and of course you know
because i'm asking you this question
that i know what the answer is to this
at least i know a little bit this is
another active research area
but let's go back to our favorite
example of the cream
mixing into coffee it begins in a very
low entropy state
the cream and the coffee mix together it
ends up in a high entropy state
but that early low entropy state is very
simple right all the creams on the top
all the coffee's on the bottom
that final high entropy state is also
very simple everything's mixed together
it's
in between it's that intermediate state
on the journey from low entropy to high
entropy where
things look complicated where the cream
and the coffee are mixing together
in unpredictable ways forming little
swirls little fractal patterns that
would require a lot of information
to specify so that's the secret and we
have a lot to learn still to go about
this but basically
complexity naturally arises
on the journey from low entropy to high
entropy
this is a we think a fundamental feature
of how the universe works
that there's something about the journey
from a
simple beginning with very very low
entropy
to a simple ending with very very high
entropy
that can give rise to complexity so
entropy just goes up
but complexity first goes up and then
goes down
it's a temporary phenomenon which might
make you
pleased to understand what's going on
maybe a little worried
about the ephemeral nature of things
like that in the universe and indeed
this is not just a story about cream and
coffee
this is a story we can tell about the
universe as a whole
the big bang was about 14 billion years
ago and right after the big bang the
universe was very low entropy
also very simple it was hot dense smooth
rapidly expanding that's all you need to
know
over time what happens is the universe
expands and cools
and structures begin to form gravity
pulls things together and we can see
this we can take an
image of the background radiation from
the big bang from a few hundred thousand
years after the beginning
you can see the first faint traces of
structures forming
today 14 billion years later our
universe is rich with structures
there are planets stars galaxies people
clusters
voids it's a very lumpy interesting
exciting kind of universe
but that's temporary it's not going to
last forever
stars use up their fuel they burn out
they go dark
stars fall into black holes even black
holes don't last forever
in the 1970s stephen hawking taught us
black holes
radiate out into the universe and
eventually evaporate away
completely we think roughly speaking
that
10 to the 100 years from now which is a
long time even by long now standards
all the black holes in the universe will
have evaporated away into almost
nothing we think that the universe is
expanding and it's going to keep
expanding forever we don't know that for
sure remember predicting the future is
hard
but that's the best current theory we
have so the very far future of the
universe
is very high entropy but once again very
very
simple we for what it's worth live in
the exciting part
of the history of the universe and we
are part of that excitement
and maybe this is a story you're willing
to believe on general grounds complexity
comes and goes etc but
the leap from there to the specific
complexity of a living organism might be
a little bit hard to swallow right
you in fact you're taught sometimes i
wish you weren't but it's true
you're taught that living organisms are
somehow fighting against entropy they're
resisting entropy right
i think the opposite of that is true my
friend michael russell who's one of the
world's leading researchers
in the beginning of life the origin of
life here on earth once told me
the purpose of life is to hydrogenate
carbon dioxide
now that might not be the purpose of
your life what he meant was
why did life start in the first place in
his theory and no one agrees
okay there's very large number of
different theories that are competing
right now but he has one of the
interesting ones
russell says there was an overabundance
of carbon dioxide
in the early earth and that was a low
entropy way
for those carbon atoms to be it would be
much higher entropy
for those carbon atoms to get rid of
their oxygen and take on hydrogen
convert into methane okay hydrogenate
the carbon dioxide
the problem was there's no simple way to
get
from there to here from carbon dioxide
to methane no simple reaction makes that
happen
what does make it happen is a complex
network of reactions under exactly the
right circumstances
so russell used this idea to make a
prediction
that underneath the oceans there should
be warm
hydrothermal vents of a very very
specific chemistry
and after he made that prediction it was
shown to be
true we found things like the lost city
formation
at the bottom of the atlantic ocean a
warm hydrothermal vent
which have exactly this complex chemical
structure
and russell's idea is that this network
of chemical reactions can get
caught up in a vessel a cell membrane
break away and form a precursor to life
here on earth now again we don't know
it's one theory but the point i'm trying
to make
is the existence of life is not
something that is a struggle against
the growth of entropy it is something
that is made possible
by the growth of entropy and once you
have that once you have these little
complex networks
that are using up the entropy around
them they can last for a long time
i want to emphasize this because this
goes into not just the origin of life
but what you are doing
right now the nature of us as bodies and
beings here in the world
roughly speaking you can think about
things that persist
okay configurations of matter that last
for a long time
there's two ways to be a persistent
object here in the world
one way is to be made of individual
pieces individual atoms and molecules
that are themselves more or less
stationary we might call this
microstasis the chair underneath you
right now
is made of a whole series of molecules
that are held together in a rigid
pattern
they're not doing anything they're not
going anywhere there's a solidity to it
which maintains over time
but there's another paradigm which we
might call homeostasis
where you have patterns that persist
over time
even if the individual pieces that make
up those patterns
are moving that sounds a lot more like
life to me right it's not just life
think about the great red spot on
jupiter this is a storm
okay this is a storm of swirling gases
in the atmosphere of jupiter that has
persisted for hundreds of years
it's not that there's one lump there
that is absolutely stationary
the pattern maintains over time
that's what you are that's what i am we
are patterns that get
maintained over time because there's a
lot of activity beneath the surface
you can try your best to be completely
stationary right you can still your
breathing
lower your heart rate enter a meditative
state but whether you notice it or not
at the cellular level there's a lot of
action going on a lot of atp molecules
are being created and used
atps are little batteries that fuel your
system
you can stay as still as you want but if
you plop your body
out there in the desert away from fuel
away from water and food and so forth
you will not last
for very long what we really do
is we maintain the persistence of the
patterns we call our body
by taking in fuel from the outside and
using that for maintenance for
homeostasis
why is that possible because entropy is
increasing
all of those processes that keep us
maintained
require an increase in entropy of the
universe
here on earth mostly that comes from the
sun
right we think to ourselves what does
the sun do for us as in terms of life
here on earth
the sun gives us energy you might be
tempted to say and that's true
but it's not the whole story the earth
radiates into space
just as much energy as it gets from the
sun the total amount of energy here on
earth is not really changing
that much the difference is for every
one
photon of light we get from the sun the
earth radiates
20 photons into outer space we get
visible light from the sun
we radiate infrared light out into space
so
20 photons of infrared with one
twentieth of the energy each
is what we do to the energy we get from
the sun
so in other words the sun gives us
energy
in a low entropy form one photon
we increase its entropy we do
photosynthesis we eat our food we think
we listen to talks we make great
speeches
that we radiate out into the universe
the same energy we got but with a much
higher entropy
that's what enables all of the marvelous
activity
that brings us to life here on earth and
that process
is to come back to where we started
what explains the idea that we feel that
time is passing around us
that imbalance between past present and
future caused by the fact that
entropy is increasing so if you think
about it
you think about yourself right now at
the present moment you are in some
configuration right your body is doing
some particular thing and a day ago or a
second ago it was also
in some particular configuration a
second from now or a day from now it
will be in some particular configuration
but you don't know right you don't have
exact knowledge you have
vague knowledge of what your body's
doing right now you don't even have
perfect knowledge of that
you kind of have a memory of where it
was and you can predict where it will be
and let's think about that process not
the scale of days or years but of
seconds or
milliseconds okay the point is we are
constantly carrying with us in our minds
an image of our body and not just an
image of our body right now we have a
pretty good idea of what our bodies are
doing right now even though it's
imperfect right we don't have perfect
knowledge of anything
we also carry around where our body was
we carry the memory of what we were
doing just a tiny fraction of a second
ago
and we project into the future our our
brains are constantly doing this
they're making predictions about where
we will be where
our bodily configuration will be a
fraction of the second in the future
and they're constantly comparing its
prediction
as we made it to what we're perceiving
as where we are right now
and to what we think we were doing in
the past
it is that constant process of
comparison
past present and future on millisecond
time scales
that's what gives us the feeling that
time is passing
the feeling that we are moving through
time because there's an imbalance
we know a little bit more about the past
we make predictions about the future
we constantly take in more data more
information and we
update and every single update gives us
the impression
that we are moving through time that's
not just us of course that's not just
human beings
every animal species does something like
this but we human beings do a little bit
more than the average
animal species we think about the future
in different ways okay every animal
species needs to react
to its present circumstance but you know
that human beings can react to a lot
more
than a fraction of a second right we can
think about the future we can
contemplate it we can plan
we can imagine different possible
futures
that is a very precious gift that took a
long time for evolution
to give us malcolm mciver who is a
neuroscientist at northwestern
university has a theory about this
his theory is that it comes back down to
the first
fish that climbed onto land okay you may
have heard of the fossil tiktaalik
which is probably one of the first fish
that climbed onto land
and mciver's idea is that when you're a
fish you can't
see that far in front of you even if
you're in very clear water the
attenuation length of light in water is
only a few meters you see
things in front of you but not very far
away so all of the evolutionary pressure
when you live in the water
is to see something and react to it
right away
is it friend is it faux is it food
whereas when you climb onto land
now you can see forever roughly speaking
right on a clear day there's no optical
to how far you can see
you can see things so far away it will
take you
time to interact with them in some way
and therefore
a new possibility opens up for evolution
to choose to develop in your brain which
is
the possibility to see something and
rather than just instantly react to it
think about the possible things you
could do
hypothesize different scenarios imagine
them
this idea is the birth of imagination
and in fact you can see how evolution
did this evolution uses
things over and over again and
neuroscientists have shown
that the part of your brain that lights
up when you're imagining a scene in the
future
is the same part of your brain that
lights up when you're remembering a
scene
from the past it's this ability
to imagine different future hypothetical
scenarios
that really has reached its apotheosis
in human beings we are better than this
at this than any other species of
animals and this is what really
makes us particularly human you could
talk about this in many different ways
here's an
example la sagrada familia this is a
cathedral
in barcelona and it was started
constructed
back in 1883 under the guidance of
antoni gowdy he took over from other
people who started it but gowdy designed
what he thought the cathedral should
look like it's an absolute masterwork
very very complicated a million
different moving parts and different
kinds of
styles and so forth and gowdy passed
away
in 1926 and the cathedral was nowhere
near finished when he passed away
and he knew perfectly well that it would
not be finished when he passed away
but he still wanted to do it even though
he knew it wouldn't be finished when he
died
what is going on what's going on is
gowdy could use his brain
to imagine what it would be like in that
future time when the cathedral was done
and it made him happy then the point is
not that gowdy thought that he would be
a ghostly
persistence over time that would be
looking down on the cathedral and
admiring it
he gained pleasure right at that moment
from the prospect
of the future and that's something that
we humans have the ability to do
the conditions of ourselves right now
depend out on our visions of the past
and the future as well as our conditions
here in the present
so it all goes back to the cream
mixing into the coffee okay entropy
increasing over time
that's the story of the passage of time
in the universe
but it's that middle phase where the
cream is mixing into the coffee where
those little swirls
develop those swirls are us
that's what you and i are we are
temporary little bits
of complex structure in the universe
that are
part of the overall increase of entropy
over time that means we are ephemeral
we're not going to last forever that's
the bad news
okay we're not going to last for 10 to
the 10 to the 10 years we have a
lifespan we have an expiration date
but it also means we are interesting we
are
the interesting part of the universe
part of this complexity
is our ability to think about and model
ourselves and the rest of the universe
to do what psychologists call mental
time travel to imagine ourselves
not just in different places but at
different times it's that ability that
imagination
that flow through time that makes us
what we
are as human beings thank you so much
sean that was fantastic i
i especially love it when we have
somebody speaking that makes the 10 000
year
reference of long now seem like a blink
of an eye so i'd love to welcome you for
our q a
hi xander thanks very much for having me
here i think you started you started to
answer this question but i
maybe if we put it back in terms of the
egg it will make more sense
to me at least which is that so that
there's an egg that gets cracked and
goes into higher entropy state but
there's also
the part of the act that we didn't talk
about which is the formation of the egg
and the chicken
um and i think you talked about this as
you know as humans
are formed into life there's and is that
a is that a process that is going
towards higher entropy or lower entropy
when the creation of something like the
egg before it gets cracked
you know if you include a large enough
system
the only processes that we have are ones
going to higher entropy there's no
processes that go to lower entropy
you can have an entropy decrease like i
said
in the talk you can uh clean your room
that's okay
you can take a bottle of water yeah you
can put it in the refrigerator
it will cool off its entropy will go
down that's all allowed
but it's only because it's increasing
the entropy somewhere else
the reason why you can't cool your
living room
by putting a refrigerator in there and
opening the front door
is because there's more heat coming out
of the back than there is cool
going out the front so overall if you
include enough stuff
entropy always goes up and that's why i
don't like to think about
life or other complicated things as
fighting against
the increase of entropy because that's a
losing battle we're not going to win
that one
what we can do is take advantage of the
evolution
that is caused by entropy increasing and
make that into something interesting and
important and meaningful
well that that example the refrigerator
is really helpful it's like why you
can't put a fan on a sailboat and
get anywhere that's right uh right so
that that that actually makes a lot of
sense so
uh and that you can do things in a
localized system but you're you're
basically robbing that
from somewhere else in a larger system
um
yeah when we started uh building this
ten thousand year clock project
one of the first uh material scientists
that i spoke to
gave me the best picture in my head of
how we should think about uh materials
that are gonna last over ten thousand
years
he said everything is burning just at
different rates
and fundamentally like everything is
just oxidizing
and you can choose kind of which which
materials that you want to use and how
fast they you want them to oxidize
but it was it was kind of ringing to me
as you as as you spoke because
uh that's our that's our entropic
process that we get to fight
when building something well and they
weren't probably even worrying about the
fact that eventually we'll fall into a
black hole and be radiated away
into intergalactic space but the it's a
very vivid that's the 10 billion
yeah i mean everything is burning
everything is running down the most
solid thing in the world
is not 100 static that's uh that's
physics for you and the the ultimate
state we think of the universe is going
to be nothing but empty space
if you're not empty space you're not
done evolving yet and how is it that we
know
um that the moment of the big bang was
so much lower entropy than now what's
what's our what's our evidence of this
well there's sort of a two-part little
dance that we have to go through that's
a very interesting uh difficult question
one is we can just look at it right we
have
data we have the images of the cosmic
microwave background the leftover
radiation from the big bang
so we know what the conditions or we
think we know what the conditions were
like near the big bang okay and we can
calculate their entropy we have formulas
for doing this and
the reason why well sorry that was a bit
of an exaggeration
we have formulas that work in certain
circumstances we don't have the once and
for all
formula for the entropy of the universe
as a whole but what we can do is to say
what's the entropy of a black hole okay
a single black hole you know our galaxy
the milky way galaxy has a super massive
black hole in the middle that is
millions of times the mass of the sun
you can calculate the entropy of that
stephen hawking told us how to do that
the entropy of that one black hole in
the middle of our galaxy
is bigger than the entropy of the whole
universe
near the big bang so we know that
however you want to
talk about it the entropy of the
universe near the big bang was
much lower than it was today it would
have been higher if there had been black
holes around but there weren't
and that when you say a black hole has
more entropy than it than another
one are you saying that it's it's it's
more the milk has swirled more
into that coffee like you're seeing a
more homeostatic kind of
version of it you know i can't tell you
the answer to that one that's above my
pay rate so
this is one of the this is one of the
reasons why this whole subject is so
fascinating you know in the 1970s
stephen hawking and some friends of his
noticed that there was an
analogy between the behavior of black
holes and the laws of thermodynamics
and they just said oh look that's a fun
analogy and then jacob beckenstein who's
a graduate student at the time said you
know what i don't think it's an analogy
i think it's actually an equivalence
black holes really are
thermodynamic systems with entropy and
so forth and hawking
got annoyed by this he said that's
nonsense if black holes had an entropy
they would have to radiate they would
have a temperature they would give off
radiation and everyone knows that black
holes don't radiate
so he sat down to prove it and he ended
up proving
they do radiate he invented hawking
radiation which is one of the greatest
discoveries of the second half of the
20th century
in physics but we still don't know
what that entropy represents in a very
real sense so we have
from hawking and beckenstein are
formulas
that we can plug in we can tell you very
accurately how much entropy
is in a black hole just as we can tell
you the entropy of a cup of coffee
but for the cup of coffee we can say oh
because there's molecules there's
cream molecules and there's coffee
molecules and if you say well what is
it that are the equivalents of the
molecules in the case of the black hole
we just don't know right now
interesting and i wonder if you know
part of the issue is that we don't have
good visualization tools for
you know that we keep showing time on a
timeline um for instance but
have you come up are there good
visualization tools that would kind of
break this paradigm better
or show it better for people you know
it's a good question
uh i don't have any good uh answers as
to what a good visualization tool would
be
what i find very interesting is that
there is no universality in how people
visualize time so if you become a
professional physicist
and you specialize in relativity or
cosmology
right space-time and the expansion of
the universe all that thing
and you want to draw a picture of the
universe what we call a space-time
diagram
for you time runs upward from the bottom
to the top
in every space-time diagram ever written
if you're a particle physicist
and you have two particles bumping into
each other and scattering off and you
want to draw a picture of that a fineman
diagram
to you time runs from left to right if
you're a computer scientist
talking about how algorithms go to you
time runs from top to bottom
so there are different ways that we
represent
time in space and now uh analogically
and uh there's a whole nother you know
hour-long talk to be given about how
that gets represented in language
different spatial metaphors different
temporal metaphors and so
whatever our metaphors are it's hard for
us to break free of them
you might be right maybe there's a
better one that would help us think
about this
right and you mentioned how time and
linguistics are are
linked and i mean i assume that also one
of the things that we do some language
projects here at long now and
you know it's it's often said that you
know if you lose a language you lose a
world view
uh as well and um have you found that
there's other cultures either
indigenous or modern that kind of in
inherently understand time the more the
way physics
physicists do ah so i don't know
i what what i what i completely agree
with is the idea that
different cultures do understand time
very differently
um and some of them might become closer
to physics than
to sort of what we might call the modern
physics
attitude toward it but i'm just not
educated enough on
uh what those are you know and and if
there are any
you know i don't want to give either our
culture or any other cultures too much
credit
because you know when it comes to things
like the
large-scale history of the universe um
well there's two options the universe is
eternal or it's finite in time
and so some cultures had stories where
it was finite it had a beginning
other stories where it was infinite and
one of them is going to be right but
there's only two choices
neither one of them were on the basis of
data from telescopes right because even
right now
we do not know whether the universe
truly had a beginning or whether the big
bang was just a phase
so i think that there's lots of
different metaphors lots of different
stories lots of different cultural ways
of thinking about time
but even modern physics doesn't have the
right picture yet so
i'm not going to give credit to anybody
quite yet right
yeah we had a speaker um early on who uh
dan everett who
studies the praha in central or south
america and they have a very very
clearly a very different conception of
time i'm not sure if it's more aligned
with physics or not
but much less about past and future um
we have a great question here from
uh raphael from the facebook feed
says hi i'm a teenager it's very common
for people my age to go through
existential crisis because of how
massively large the universe is
and how little significance our
individual lives have
is feeling my newt the right approach or
for visualizing ourselves
or how do you deal with this conception
of time in your own life
yeah you know raphael you're not wrong
to think that you're very very tiny
compared to the universe on the other
hand
you're very very big compared to an
electron and on the third hand who cares
who cares how big you are who cares how
long you're going to last
i do think it's important to appreciate
that we're finite we're ephemeral as i
said
in the talk we're not going to last
forever and therefore
whatever it is that you find meaningful
and important and motivating
in your life it can't be that you're
going to
leave an impression on the universe that
lasts literally forever because there
are no such impressions
and i actually find this liberating
rather than leading to existential
despair it takes the burden away from me
to try to do something to the universe
that will actually
leave an imprint that lasts forever the
imprints that we leave on the universe
are finite but that doesn't make them
any less important for that
don't think about the universe think
about the people who you can affect
including yourself
uh the impact that you can have here and
in the near future
that's hard enough and it also matters
more than enough i would say
kevin is asking if we know that there's
dark matter and there's
dark energy is there dark time no it's
the equivalent
no all right well because let me
amplify you know time is not a substance
time is not something you can have a cup
of here's a cup of time right
dark matter is a substance it's a set of
particles you can move it around you can
say oh there's more dark matter over
here than over there
time is a label in modern physics right
it's a it's a way that we think about
where you are
in the universe in space-time what
exists is the universe
time is a language that we use to talk
about the universe
so there's no sort of equivalent
different version of time that would be
darker or something like that now
again having said that there will always
be people who disagree
you know that in the universe in which
we live there's three dimensions of
space
there's one dimension of time so it's
very very natural to say well why aren't
there two dimensions of time or three or
something like that and people have
tried to do that
none of these attempts has really led to
increasing our understanding of the
universe in fact they tend to make
things much much worse
so at least as far as we currently
understand it
the best way of thinking about the
universe is for time to be unique for
there to be one direction of time one
dimension of space time that we call
the temporal one again as a good
scientist you should always be open to
changing your mind in the future if
if good information comes along
and that actually leads into a great
question from uh stephen from the
facebook feed as well
um who's asking about some of the recent
quantum experiments
and how they can entangle the future in
the past
um in some ways there's is that changing
some of
notions of causality and and entropy
that
maybe there's connections beyond between
and around the present from the future
impasse so here i will give you
uh my personal slightly grumpy view
about these things because uh
now we've moved on from time which is
easy to quantum mechanics which is hard
and what i mean by hard is that
the greatest theoretical physicists in
the world don't agree
on how quantum mechanics works what it
says etc i have a point of view
on this i just wrote a book called
something deeply hidden where i
explained to you what my point of view
is
but for the purposes of this particular
question here is my point of view
no there's no such thing as entanglement
at different moments of time not really
you
can choose to talk about the quantum
evolution of the universe
in such a way that you can kind of make
sense of such a thing but
you don't have to when you talk about
different
uh parts of the universe at one moment
of time
there's an objective fact of the matter
are they entangled with each other or
are they not and everyone agrees on that
and you can talk about it and use it etc
in the conventional way of talking about
quantum mechanics that's all there is
the state of the universe exists at each
moment of time
just like in newtonian physics right in
newtonian physics as we talked about
if you have the positions like the solar
system positions and velocities of
everything at
one moment of time you can predict the
past present and future
same thing in quantum mechanics if you
know the quantum state at one moment of
time you can predict what's going to
happen
so i don't personally like to talk about
entanglement between different moments
of time you can but it seems to be just
an attempt to make things seem even more
confusing than they really are
kevin kelly is also asking uh how has
your own life changed
since since learning this is this aside
from this is something that you teach
but does this change the way
you actually think about your
the way your life works well um in a in
a fairly direct
way it has because you know i
uh since i was 10 years old i wanted to
be a theoretical physicist
and i read about black holes and the big
bang and particles and i
i did it i eventually you know got to
the point where i was doing that
professionally
when i was in college as an
undergraduate i also discovered
philosophy
and i fell in love with that also but it
seemed to be like a very different kind
of thing like the kind of philosophy
that i studied was actually political
and moral philosophy and there was some
philosophy of science in there
but uh that wasn't what my favorite kind
of philosophy was
it wasn't until you know i was a
professor already
and i thought a little bit about
cosmology a lot about cosmology actually
but i was thinking about the early
universe
and i got connected with philosophers
who weren't
doing philosophy of science in the sense
they were studying how science works
they were doing philosophy of science in
the sense they were studying how the
universe works
but in a more philosophical way and what
i realized was
they were making more sense when it came
to talking about the universe and time
than my physicist friends were and so i
became more philosophical
myself and that has continued on and i
started thinking about quantum mechanics
and how that works
how time works how space time itself
works how probability works
and these days what i do professionally
in my research career
is not even recognizable as cosmology
anymore
so in the down-to-earth sense that it
has changed my intellectual direction
uh very very much thinking thinking
about time was
my entry into thinking about the
universe in a more philosophical way
nice well and we have a question from uh
toss rock from
youtube it's actually asking about you
know how you got involved in science and
then
going on to doing things like working in
the movie industry and
advising on science fiction movies as we
were just discussing but i think
maybe another way to to think about this
is you know if if somebody was starting
a science career now in in this space
um what would you tell them what would
you tell them to learn
oh you know what's the interesting space
for a young scientist to get into so
that eventually they get to be as cool
as you advising
marvel honestly there's the two secrets
to becoming a science advisor for
hollywood are
number one live in los angeles that's
where it's located uh
number two have an at least medium-sized
public profile be out there on social
media or writing books or doing youtube
or set etc
and they will find you there's no
systematic way you don't apply for a job
uh
it's not a job you don't get paid it's
just kind of fun to talk to
directors and screenwriters about their
hollywood movies i got a sweatshirt once
an ironman sweatshirt that was kind of
fun
um but the other version of that
question is you know how do you get into
doing interesting science forgetting
about for the moment uh
movie consulting or anything like that
because there is a fundamental flaw in
the system where if you're like me
uh so i said i got interested in physics
when i was 10 years old so that's the
middle 1970s
and what are you going to do you're
going to be reading about what is the
most interesting physics going on
at that point in time so i was reading
about quarks and black holes and the big
bang
and all that is great it's still great
now
but what you do for a living is not
going to be what's interesting when you
first
stumble across the field because there's
decades in between somehow right so
it's very hard to sort of plan ahead for
what will
be the most interesting stuff when you
become a grown up scientist
so my advice is you know to think
broadly you know to be
open to all the different interesting
things going on um
be ready to say well you know what i
hadn't even thought of this whole
field that seems really cool let me at
least take it seriously you know
learn everything you can and put off to
the last minute choosing once and for
all what has to be your specialty
nice so we're going to be wrapping up
here shortly but i think one of the
things that you said that i thought was
really
interesting is that this idea that while
we have a lot more information about the
past
we obviously have much more influence on
the future and i think it's an
interesting thing that in our time
actually people feel as though they're
having less and less influence
on their future but i think it's a nice
message this idea that that's actually
the one thing we do have it influences
over
and so that that physics backs that up i
think is is really
great um and you mentioned one of your
recent books um
what are you what are you working on now
as slash next i know that
this topic was kind of a kind of dipping
into your past a bit but and which i
thank you for but um what what is your
next
current and next uh work well the reason
why i thought
i was very excited about doing this talk
is because even though i wrote a book
on the arrow of time over 10 years ago
now called from eternity to here
i'm actually again doing research on it
so
i'm doing research on this this question
of why
is it that you can have
effects and causes but the effects
always come after
the causes in other words why is the
arrow of causality aligned with the
arrow of time you know i i talk about
the arrow of time
a lot of my friends in physics or
philosophy will talk about multiple
different
arrows of time the psychological arrow
the influence that we talked about the
thermodynamic arrow
so one ongoing project is relating them
all
to each other and i'm someone who
believes that the increase
of entropy is the reason why all these
other arrows exist
but it's easy to say that out loud it's
hard to prove it with equations
so i'm i'm working on that as a as a
research project using
ideas from causal networks and bayesian
thinking
as well as thermodynamics and entropy
and philosophy of time
cool well thank you so much for joining
us this was so great to have you and to
actually get a kind of a very
fundamental
sense of time and us in it my pleasure
xander thanks very much for having me on
thank you and i'd like to thank you our
along now audience um we actually have
several talks coming up in the future
um that cross over uh fundamentals uh
in science such as color and weather and
how trees communicate
so please join us for the weeks to come